nos dicen que la recta hace es tangente
al círculo o en el punto ce la recta
hace es tangente a este círculo con
centro o en el punto c y a partir de esa
información nos preguntan cuál es la
longitud del segmento hace este segmento
de acá te recomiendo que detengas el
vídeo e intentes el problema por tu
cuenta
bueno voy a suponer que ya lo intentaste
aquí el paso clave consiste en darse
cuenta que ese es un radio que llega a
este punto que justo es el punto de
tangencia de la recta hace por lo tanto
tenemos que hacer la recta hace son
perpendiculares es decir este ángulo de
acá que estoy marcando en naranja mide
90 90 grados y si tenemos un ángulo de
90 grados aquí entonces el triángulo a c
es un triángulo rectángulo y a ese
triángulo le podemos aplicar el teorema
de pitágoras muy bien notemos que este
lado de acá el lado o se mide 3 y de
este lado en el lado
hacemos que de ave mis dedos y aquí
tenemos una longitud que parece
desconocida la uve pero no tenemos que
eso simplemente es un radio del círculo
sí entonces como es un radio del círculo
y aquí dice que el radio mide 3 v
también mide 3
voy a marcarle aquí que mide 3
y por lo tanto todo el segmento
mide 5 entonces desde aquí
hasta acá mide 5 y esto está fantástico
porque entonces en el triángulo
ya conocemos la longitud de este lado de
este lado de acá y sabemos que es un
triángulo rectángulo así que a partir de
esta información podemos encontrar la
longitud del tercer lado que le voy a
llamar
vamos a utilizar el teorema de pitágoras
el teorema de pitágoras nos diría que x
al cuadrado x al cuadrado más 3 al
cuadrado más 3 elevado al cuadrado es
igual a 5 al cuadrado y sabemos que 5
queda de este lado en la igualdad el del
lado derecho en donde queda solito
porque 5 es la longitud de la hipotenusa
ya que este lado es el lado que es
opuesto al ángulo de 90 grados bueno
vamos a resolver esta ecuación tenemos
que x al cuadrado más 3 al cuadrado o
sea 99 es igual a 5 al cuadrado es decir
25 20 5 restando 9 de ambos lados
obtenemos que x al cuadrado es igual a
y por lo tanto por lo tanto 16 x es
igual a 4
entonces la longitud de x es 4 y por lo
tanto la longitud de ac es 4